they can tell us we're crazy and we can
say well you haven't seen anything yet
because there are things glass is the
sequel to both unbreakable and split
that is set to release later this month
it ties together the M night Shyamalan
superhero trilogy that started with
David Dunne discovering his powers
before all the personalities within
Kevin crumb finally manifested within
the Beast at the end of split we saw a
scene that teased the two facing off
against each other and glass sees the
culmination of this the titular
character is of course mr. glass played
perfectly by samuel l.jackson in
unbreakable in that film
we followed super-powered David Dunn as
he was slowly mented by his opposite mr.
glass who had very fragile bones that
led to a lot of breaks within his life
at the end of the film glass was
arrested when it was discovered by Dunn
who has the ability to see people's
pasts that glass had caused several
tragedies in order to find gun the
upcoming film centers around glass
attempting to manipulate Krum into
believing that he is a God and that he
needs to bring balance to a broken world
class once the population of the world
to witness the super-powered beings that
live among them and he's using chrome to
deliver this message this of course
follows up on unbreakable in which glass
informed David that he was super-powered
and we will see the effect repeat here
this is why crumb is seen kidnapping
girls in the trailer he is in service to
bringing balance and this obviously will
throw him into a head-on collision with
Dunn juxtaposing this dr. le staple
played by Sarah Paulsen is attempting to
convince the characters that they are
ordinary which again follows the
opposites aesthetic that was so
prevalent in unbreakable
in the trailer staple states my work
concerns a particular type of delusion
of grandeur it's a growing field I
specialize in those individuals who
believe they are superheroes the three
of you have convinced yourselves you
have extraordinary gifts like something
out of a comic book this highlights the
biggest thing I think will be prevalent
in the film and that is that Shamma
Lamma is building his own shared
superhero universe similar to the MCU
now there may be some heavy spoilers
here so if you don't want to know
anything about the film's ending then I
highly suggest that you turn off now as
this has been confirmed by several
sources so you have been warned but in
the film's ending apparently all of the
characters are said to die in an epic
climax this then forces the world to
acknowledge that superheroes exist and
that those with abilities will step
forward and start a new trilogy that
focuses on the aftermath of their
faceoff obviously this is all the rumors
at the moment but it has been confirmed
by quite reputable news sources of
course we will find out in the coming
weeks whether this is true or not
I'd love to hear your thoughts and
predictions on what you think will
happen in the movie or if you have any
extra information so make sure to leave
that in the comments below if you
enjoyed this video then please like it
and make sure you check out my breakdown
of the latest watchmen teaser trailer
which will be linked at the end of this
video this is the channel for people who
are super into superheroes so if that's
the kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this I've been definition you've
been the best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
[Music]